what did you want to be when you were
little
a vet what were your favorite animals to
put down
your hair is fantastic are you like a
hairdresser it looks so neat
what's what's your vocation
an engineer holy [__] [__] yeah
[__] stem girls in stem yeah re
a [__] the power what do you what do you
engineer
you sell commercial HVAC equipment holy
[__] you saw those forest fires you were
like money
[Applause]
wow wow it's the what's the highest BTU
you go to
come on you got to be quicker with that
two million where are you selling two
million okay you're very bad at your job
of selling commercial HVAC are you also
in the HVAC industry
what do you do
a water quality technologist
holy [__] this is amazing 50 years ago
it would be like what'd you do I cook
and I clean and this is
you wouldn't even be here
but now you're selling air conditioners
you're making sure the water's drinkable
where in New York has the best water
quality
you're from Canada [__] get them get
them
they started this
holy [__] so where in Canada has the
best water or where do you look after
the waterfall
in Manitoba that's moose in it moose
land growing up though
surely you didn't want to do these jobs
right this wasn't
I want to be a princess I want to be a
teacher I want to sell HVAC equipment
and not be entirely sure about the btu
what did you want to be when you were
little
a vet what were your favorite animals to
put down
that's what the job is
it's that's why you didn't do it yeah
you take the first class like all right
welcome to vet school kill this dog
[Laughter]
just cool it down if that's okay
and what did you want to be
a writer oh cool what type of writing
like a novelist oh you got what's your
novel that's inside you
it's gone now oh
tragic isn't it when you see the Hope
die in the eyes
now I just work for the man you're
looking over here like these are two you
know like what do you guys do
Finance [__] yeah bet your parents
are well proud of you right
you don't know about that you don't know
about that what does your parents want
you to do
whatever you wanted
self-fulfilling um did you want to do
Finance
um
a teacher and then you were like [__]
the kids get the paper get the bag all
right cool and then my my Ralph Lauren
t-shirt wearing dude has this already
been touched upon they got nice arms
show them off you know what uh what's
your what's your profession uh
you work at a hedge fund I thought you
could [__] buy me couldn't you
come to my home Dance with Me jester
and is that what you wanted to be when
you were little you was like I just want
to be rich
when you were a kid you dreamed about it
[__] yeah [__] ing get your goals you
see it's you know it's nice to know that
you know women can do whatever jobs they
want now but they still can't get the
goals the way that the lads can
well um I want to celebrate you guys you
know whether you're doing the job that
you wish you could or the job that you
uh didn't think ever existed so uh bam
do me a favor let's let's make up a song
for these guys let's uh let's do this
because yeah growing up I wanted to be a
rapper and I couldn't achieve that goal
fully so I became a comedian who uh
makes up rats about people in the front
row so let's uh let's do it this way the
[__] is is this because I hear jokes
about India you're like yeah whip out
the sitar I like it cool this is cool
[__] up I feel like we should be
doing this
laugh
is this a terribly terribly racist thing
to do I no have you seen a Bollywood
movie that's exactly how the dancing
goes cool fine
with chuckling feeling cringe at the way
that I dance girl on the edge of the
stage saying Finance as a kid my parents
they didn't care said pick your dreams
like stars from the air if you wanna
work in finance grab your chance you can
do it and fly by the seat of your pants
make the cash make it funny yeah you'd
be a legend over here with your hedge
fund best friend he'd be wanting to get
that back when he was a five-year-old he
was feeling sad like I got no cash no
pocket money I wanna go to a show and
see a guy who's funny and say right
jokes for me and then perform them throw
in all the Franklin's there with no worn
in the Benjamins stacking it so high
let's Scrooge McDuck but a much younger
guy who's so handsome with the big
biceps over to the right maybe I stepped
on a Minefield in a dangerous area
talking to some people it couldn't be
scarier they're from Canada they set
fire to trees and they waft the air down
beneath let me tell you about this
you're repositioning you probably got a
unit from your air conditioning blow it
to the South to the east coast burn in
the trees like these are toast we need
to make sure Americans choke on the
smoke especially that nerdy British
bloke while I rap you were like I do
HVAC I can do engineering with that I
don't know the btu that's the thermal
units I said two million you really need
to improve at the training that's a
no-braining thing over here look at the
joy that you can bring your light yes
front row at the comedy show I do the
Canadian H2O make sure that it's pure
you can drink it no cloudiness no
impurities it sinks it filtering in many
different ways that I show you the water
flows purely in Manitoba what a very
good Province the best you can get but
back in the day you wanted to be a vet
you had a Lust For Life like maybe I can
help cats with the kind of lazy eye I
put an eye patch and then Kitty can see
Nine Lives to live go on Kitty be free
but then you realize basically the cats
just die you are like no reassess my
life back into HVAC the HVAC wanted to
be a writer ever so crazy hopefully
you'll achieve it I'm not being funny
but even if you've got a best seller my
boy here would still have the most money
[Music]
foreign
you guys are lovely